I believe this is my favorite game I
used to play on the toilet in a previous
job I didn't like turned into a first
person shooter explain it to me plants
vs. zombies garden warfare Danny O'Dwyer
so basically it's plants for zombies
turning to a third person shooter look I
just planted that zombie so is that a
pun
I wanted that planted
I guess planted usually you know I like
to take nouns and turn them into verbs
when they're not actually verbs now that
case plant is actually verbs okay no not
so much
you played a bunch of this on a live
stream yesterday indeed and what we
played yesterday were the competitive
modes one is basically team deathmatch
and the other oh my god you're a
horrible abomination the other was like
this sort of state this like progressive
conquest mode we're like the zombies try
to take one garden and the plants try to
defend it and then if they fail they
have to fall back to the next garden
anyways there's two competitive modes
this is actually a cooperative mode
we're playing called garden hops is this
the one where you're actually planting
plants so I heard of that as well yes
there's a couple different ways you can
plant plants like here's here's a plant
that has been planted yeah they're
looking for cigarettes that was happily
married shooter okay yeah
huffing that's that's on his down time
he's on right now but usually that would
be the case so a lot of familiar plants
and zombies of course from the mobile
and non mobile and pretty much any
platform that ever existed
tower defense original this mode is like
pretty much tower defense we are trying
to stop these zombies from getting on
our lawn and you can you like each each
plant that you play as has three
abilities you'll see them there I just
activated the hyper ability how many
different classes of plant are there
like plants in four zombies so this is
this is a that was all like a builder
zombie hmm you're gonna see a little bit
more diverse zombies in this mode than
you will and say the team deathmatch
mode because only four playable variants
gotcha but of course like there's all
these customization options you get by
unlocking these cards which is why this
this Chomper over here
that I'd looked at before just horrible
the lava one looks like really cool
molten lava instead of just like a
regular old purple Chomper that's not a
regular so are you leveling up your
class as you're playing or is this frame
which a you can swap out like if you
don't like playing as this plant dude
you can just swap to a different plant
due to any stage like Team Fortress
style you can totally SWAT it oh go hmm
you can totally swap to different plant
dudes I'm gonna show you guys one of the
other abilities here this guy can turn
into that that's friendly is he stuck
now is your turn yeah so I've done the
turret mode I'm getting shot by I don't
even know what I was talking to Aaron
Sampson who was also on the livestream
with you yesterday yeah and he was
echoing something that I've heard in the
comments on GameSpot and across the
internet saw which is that this game
everyone wrote off straight away from
the start because let's be honest it
looks like a total you know marketing
money grab plants vs. zombies
first-person shooter the RPG is gonna
come next but he was people playing this
with you guys for like three hours
he said there's Mike his surprising
command depth yeah like meta game so
everything that's going on here
especially when you get into the the
competitive play when you're against the
zombies or you're you know you're the
plants or you're they're zombies I'm
gonna try to respawn here and he's gonna
be a different plant but like yeah the
different abilities you know like this
guy's ones a grenade ones that plant
ones that root down and do a turret ones
a speed mode but like this character the
dropper I'm looking at here can like
burrow underground and sneak up on like
what in wait why does that Yeti that is
a that is a Yeti zombie Yeti so this is
see all these zombies are AI spawned
this is just a wave based defend from
all the zombies mode so okay so you're
seeing a lot of variants come in to make
it tougher boss Tom be stuff that you
will totally be familiar with if you
were into pvz at all which but it seems
like most of the planet was little
considering how much that game is so go
down you are if you have any questions
at all by the way in the twitch chat or
on GameSpot calm or I believe also this
is the
Giant Bomb dudes and put this up on
their child as well if you have any
please throw them in there and their
folks will shoot them on to me and I
will ask Chris and what is its tell me
about this is this is this the type of
game that is fun to play because it is a
quick diversion and we are all living in
a post type of all worlds where every
titanfall world or what the actual
release is like is this the type of game
that you would actually go out and use
your own hard-earned green so like can
you imagine playing this for more than
the weekend is basically I'm kind of
getting a to put up heel flour down here
do it yay I can actually I mean the
levelling up stuff this is not sort of
extensive in the way that you would
expect from like a more you know
hardcore or popular third-person shooter
oh gosh oh go away
unsnap i've men it was the xbox one
being a jerk I've managed to never
happens you almost never have an ass
type situation I don't want to do a
Netflix yes go back Xbox Bing the matrix
okay
it's it's having a little emotional
issue so in the meantime so the game's
40 bucks right yeah so it's like your
discount level shooter sure what but you
know there's only two competitive modes
proper nah it's it's really fun I'm
really like I really enjoyed playing it
multiplayer this weekend when are you
prepping for the livestream yesterday
playing is the different classes like
you legit have different strategies and
like they're they're different abilities
kind of offset each other in in some fun
ways and and then it's just like
honestly it's really refreshing to play
a game like this that has these kind of
third person shooter mechanics that's
not gritty like sawing people who have
super gory super like heart I like that
I like that stuff yeah
but why can't game scan be fun to like
they could be like whimsical like you
can have a sense of humor about this
stuff you don't need to be super serious
you can still have the kind of balance
of action and yeah it's like not you
know it's it's it's a light in a certain
way but it's it's
totally good fun do you remember nerf
arena blast on the PC nurse remember
that game no Danny I don't deserve arena
blast it was a it was a like Unreal
Tournament one engine nerf game it was
for all intents of purpose Unreal
Tournament they just changed the names
of all the modes and changed all the
crazy disgusting weapons that destroy
people into nerf guns and it was great
it was because it was kind of fun just
to play this game and be like oh those
arrows that you would like put on the
ground and angle up and then like stomp
on the thing now fine you run into rich
kids who had a nerf groan no but I had
cousins named a best friend down the
street it was actually a jerk I've got
like had nervy of those bow things that
you crank back yeah yeah totally yeah
fun they're pretty sweet and you had a
little bit of trouble topping on too
much go server let's see if you can have
any any yes so this is not today I mean
the game is out today the GameSpot
review is up Carol and pettite rated at
a 7 which is a very good score and yeah
I agree with a lot of her review about
it's just you know like it kind of puts
a smile on your face to like try it be
in this intense fight
you're like a zombie with a little
zombie gun and then you're fighting a
sunflower yeah are beets you and it's
just soy gonna die like like like that's
a taunts yes just like smiling sunflower
demented sunflowers yeah at Nick's
they're 13 in the game spot shot asks
how addictive is this game i remember
one time for beta was out you were it
was one of those games where when you
weren't playing it you were thinking
about playing it mm-hmm
has there been times where you wanted to
play pvz but or but you've been stuck
too since when I first played pvz which
was about 48 hours ago
yep there have been times when I was not
playing that I was like but I don't
think that you know I think that it it
didn't quite it doesn't quite grab me in
the way that's something like it's I can
fall down just because that one you know
the the movement the speed of the action
is there's it's a there's a broader
spectrum of stuff going on yeah so
there's more room for strategic stuff
tactical stuff crazy crap to happen this
is definitely a more limited spectrum
yeah so we're gonna we've actually looks
like we've managed to get into a match
here okay gardens and graveyards
so I'm playing as a builder zombie which
you'll notice his most prominent and
dashing feature immediately Danny is it
is it a keg of beer and oh it's butt
crack there it is there you go yeah it's
this big ol butt so we have to go
capture this point over here the plants
are already out in full force bombarding
us I'm gonna use my like little grenade
launcher action or any of these punches
on these like AI gosh
like it's not harder no that was cheese
502 are these all what's the player cans
what are we talking about here
oh oh well this is like almost so the
max is 24 players so this looks like
it's a 10 v12 match so I'm getting
revived you can always be revived unless
you've been fully devoured by one of
those Chomper plants but in this match
the builder has like a pretty so builder
can do this thing yeah you can show his
butt off yep
it's the extra budget and I like it on
here to do do a little this thing one of
those ends one of those show you the
secondary things I got a bang clear your
sectors yep these these plants are
defending this point because what is
over here is a teleporter okay and that
is going to although these are turrets
so I'm gonna build these up to give us a
little defense only the engineer zombie
can do this stuff and the teleporter
just basically gives you a little it's
great automation there yep just gonna
head straight up bill
cement mixer starting on the back so now
my buddies can spawn out of here and
it's gonna be cool
that is a cactus I don't I do not want
to go I can operate these things I did
not know that was the thing there's so
much metagame all Gong here no gods okay
buddy's a spawn day now I have an update
that grenade yeah so it won't really be
it's a chili bean so that's what those
guys can barf up let's see I don't want
to respawn I'm gonna try to show you
guys some different characters here real
quick we got the scientist and there's
my teleport I'm gonna go over here and
now we're gonna try to move in on some
some plants the scientist is great for
like this guy who's like a long-range
dude you mean his warp and then he
doesn't know him behind him and boom
baboom great I got on the crab it roasts
right from behind yeah yeah I like it
and so now I'm like actually behind the
capture point coming in which means I
might be flanked by some spawning
zombies but and I'm actually gonna heal
myself up well probably do that it's
let's let's draw it right there come on
man I'm doing do my he'll do to capture
this I've seen enough with plants vs.
zombies oh my god job there you go done
oh that's class vs. zombies were playing
on the extra five